who shot alexander hamilton in that
famous duel
[Music]
all right let's go to the phones and see
who's out there
hello
[Music]
excuse
[Music]
that classic dairy industry ad campaign
encouraged americans to put milk in the
fridge but consumers taste have been
changing milk consumption is down 42
percent from what it was a half century
ago from 247 pounds per person in 1975
to just 144 pounds today and that's put
a squeeze on dairy farms there are about
half as many as there were in 2003 a
loss of more than 38 thousand licensed
operations but those that remain are
finding ways to adapt to this changing
world we visited two upstate new york
farms with two very different approaches
they all be out here on the pasture
grazing in the morning
maybe not this time of year but possibly
with as warm as it is
walk through tom murray's old dairy farm
and you sense an emptiness in a space
once teeming with life
so this is where you did it all yeah
this is where we milked our cows this is
where a lot of the herd was
kept
vacant stalls where 90 holsteins heard
it together to deliver their yield do
you miss them we don't miss losing money
if we could make money we still be doing
it
losing money forced murray to shut down
milk production in 2019
and sell off his prized heifers even the
descendants of his best lucinda well she
set the world's milk production record
in 1997 21 gallon a day 21 gallons it
was the average about 14 is about a
hundred pounds of milk per day per cow
14 gallon wow
yeah we had good cows so to make that
decision was very
personal but also uh
very uh
needed for economic stability of this
property still gets to you oh yeah
when we're competing against the
walmarts and the lows of this world on
this size scale we just don't cut it we
just don't have that scale of efficiency
so this first generation dairy farmer
specialized he became the big cheese of
miranda cheese
now this is red pepper flake
um
and the heat will come late it's not
late late how late well at the finish
how hot well i don't know your tolerance
level but it'll be fine unlike milk
cheese consumption has nearly doubled
over the last four decades new york is
already among the nation's top producers
and ranks number one in yogurt cottage
cheese and sour cream production well
we're trying to
create a market to make our own cheese
and create a destination here in the
finger lakes it just happens to go good
with all the craft beverage facilities
that are already here
and he continued his expansion with live
music and tasting events
that's one approach watch over here
these guys are being released doug young
has another
so it's all about efficiency he went big
increasing the number of cows at spruce
haven farms from 120 to 2000. you have
to have a high levels of production
production per cow and per farm then you
can spread the cost of expertise and
there's so many areas of expertise in
dairy that there's no way one person can
be good at all of them so essentially
diversification
is the key specialization whoever is
responsible for breeding the cows or
feeding the cows or
taking care of sick cows they had to be
so good at it
they have to be as good as a
veterinarian but that wasn't all he
joined forces with his neighbors
international trade is actually
phenomenal former investment banker
turned milkman kevin ellis heads cayuga
milk ingredients a co-op of 30 farmers
including young who banded together 13
years ago to figure out their future the
farmers of this region were shipping
their milk as far as new york city
close to boston down into southern new
jersey to find milk markets 10 percent
of their gross income was going to
transportation costs that did not seem
to be sustainable so we started to
envision building a plant locally
to shorten the hall distance that plant
also helped farmers erase the middleman
they process and market their own
products they even handle research and
development
one of their solutions dehydrating milk
into powder to lessen its weight which
made it highly profitable
to give you an idea it was costing two
dollars and fifty cents a hundred weight
to get product to new york city
when we take the water out
we can move that same product to
shanghai for
67 cents
and then there's this
the manure digester what you're smelling
is power
young sons luke and dustin are behind
their sustainability operation retention
of a million and a half gallons of raw
manure under the cover there's no oxygen
and it's at a temperature of about 104
degrees so at that temperature the
microbes in there really break down the
manure and release the methane and we
produce just over 500 kilowatts an hour
what does that mean it powers our farm
in about two farms the same size
a utility savings of two hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year for this four
000 acre farm a significant reduction in
their carbon footprint moving one day
they hope to net zero is it catching on
i believe it really is the technology is
getting to a point where it makes sense
for people to do you know it's easy to
do something like this when you're not
carrying the entirety of the risk
so sustainability is a new word for an
old
principle
stewardship which really comes from the
bible so now that we have the ability to
advance the science and measure the data
like carbon footprint per unit of
nutrition or nitrogen footprint we can
measure it and manage it do you want
other farms to do what you've done it's
clear now that the global food companies
and consumers are expecting it so we
need to provide what the consumers need
and what
oh wow
ensuring a future for the next
generation of dairy
and farmers